第1回匂いで当てられないもの戦士系
[音楽]
あああああれでこちらの-カーですね各自に何がわかりづらいものを事前に準備して
もらいました
持ってきますねバチッああいうロンドン芸があると思うんですけども
パパっにおいて良い嗅いだらああこらああああっ
あーこれ
4日あなたは6学生において特徴的で馬鹿にすると思うんですけどもその中でもこの3
人がをのを考えたこれ良い嗅いだだけでは分からないであろう
new のあるものをちょっと準備してもらって手で持ってきてもらってそれが残りの
2人で貼ってるというね簡単なゲームを別シェアで僕はなかなか難しいと思いますよ
[音楽]
そんなに彼らちゃんが特徴的だけど勝った勝ったとか自分たちベル文書を
が2人者物件って挨拶してなくねカラーいいじゃんけっぽい
ちょ
2番手わーっはっはっは
じゃんけんぽんちょ
一番一番いい新高ジャパンても先は準備の方酔えますよ
膣剤者以外の骨2人がいるんで一番当てた数が多かった人だよ
勝者という
うーん
ペインこれです
もーもーもーもー貼っていっ
ん
22メタンでなぁんがなんか無粋な
ダッジませいくような人さんいろん
[音楽]
いい一緒にバインやりスレああカッターの刃がー
わかったわかったよこれ着たはこれが身近な人すぐわかるんだ
答えてもらいまーすせーの信号デー
大富3大正解です a
ねなるほどに何か実は特徴的だけど
データを作っていられた桜
わかんない人ぐらいのフルーツ持ってきたのかななんてったって注目する
うん
ん
2問目は私選んだのはこちらでございますまま至って普通と思っていうかで体釜山で
結構でもあるよよく
再掲ではないじゃあそれは人によりけりだと思う
[音楽]
ua のかっわかったわかったよこれ
音やんだこれはなにこれええ
全然わかんないねえ飯戦闘艦な姉頻尿ではない
いやー
味は正解をしましょう異性の前でいきますよ
のすごいた様に皆さんうふん
なれのはてって
世界だああああ
なんで分かった俺も
なんだった俺ジャンスカ置いてあるぞ
ふあさあ
というわけで1ポイント2ポイントになりません
これも破れ者は爪が失敗したらああそうかいそうかじゃないじゃんよ
うーん
何超えてこれはん
ん
ザップから逆から読ん音音おとおとまとほんと準備からまだ準備準備つだねなんか
やばい本当に今恋で姉の世代だけえってないんじゃない
pa
jr 近い違ってきますね
べっぐらーい4なにこれ
楽器
で先発だろう愛ちゃん入っちゃういや
頑張るとねー
大家ぽいんだよな結果知ってる
うーんちょっと1回問う
体育館ぽよろしいですがえっ
体育館でこれはマイク感度でこれ買ってるッ
あっ
あっこっち土地に行っていえーちゃんで5分
全然なんか放流感じ7話が分かったん
ニットパッと思いましたじゃあいます製のグローブ等チーズも全然違うの
えっローブでも体感するでもはしそうな開けてください
オープン
なにこれこれは昔今から7年ほど前に死んだおじいちゃんがその前さらに20年くらい
前に使っていた
ヘアワックスのアレなわけです俺ちゃん使ってたやつ
グローブとサブカー
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
バッハ
はいはいれないんですか
はい ax のクリックで所大生髪へ
nao
クイックだねしてクリックでしょ
なんだよなーんかしかない